my name is Kier I am product manager in
Google cloud I work on cloud pub/sub and
that means I get to talk to a lot of
data engineers across the world both
users of cloud pub/sub and Kafka and
things like data flow and bigquery
so we'll today's session would be about
using those tools now there are a couple
things that are interesting about here
that is me in this context one is as I
said I get to work on cloud pub/sub
which is a very large distributed
service that we try to run with very
good availability and we've learned a
few things about using real-time
streaming data to help us do that so I
will share some of that experience to
help motivate by stream analytics is
important to answer the question why
this matters the second reason is that
as I said it's I'm lucky enough to have
it as part of my job to to speak to a
lot of data engineering teams and so
I've learned quite a bit over over my
last few years doing that so I'm
grateful for that and I've learned that
it's a pretty interesting time in the
industry with a lot of interesting
people so I'm going to if I'm going to
take just a few seconds out of this talk
to say if there's somebody you don't
know next to you they're probably an
interesting data engineer say hello you
don't have to if you're uncomfortable
but I lock wordly stand here for 10
seconds so really shake shake the head
Hey
alright alright I hope you met another
person and after after this talk you can
you can ask them what they do and so
I'll so what I'll what I'll do is I'll
stop with a with the corny jokes and
I'll try to answer a couple questions
which is you know really one question
why do we care about stream analytics
why why do we need fresh data which is
really what this is about
and then I'll hand this off to to a
person who who actually has had quite a
bit of success with building stream
analytic systems on GCP that's simon
foreman who was a head of behavioural
data engineering at itv that's one of
England's premier TV networks and i'm so
you'll tell you a lot more about about
that so let's get into it
so stream analytics is about moving from
dealing with files to give you a figure
10 megabytes plus to dealing with one
kilobyte at a time all right as soon as
the thing happens you process it and
that requires a bit of a shift in
thinking a new kind of technology you
need new storage technology you need new
processing technology and you need a new
way to access your data so on the
storage again we've we've had tremendous
amount of success with technologies for
handling blobs large files now you need
things like cloud pub/sub and Apache
Kafka that are great at accepting
appends and persisting them on disk at
one kilobyte at a time all right there
are no more files they're kind of
infinite right so you need to be able to
deal with that and you need to be able
to let multiple distributed clients tail
these files without introducing latency
so that's a new kind of that's a new
kind of storage technology on the
processing side you have now jobs that
don't just come up process a file and
shut down you have jobs that run for not
hours but days and months and sometimes
years so you need something that's
stable enough to do this you need
something that can recover and heal
itself when it's not having a good time
and you need something that is going to
be able to help you deal with data that
is unbounded all right there are no
files there's no end to file so how do
you how do you know when you've gotten
everything it turns out it's not a
trivial problem so tools like data
flowin and spark and an Apache spark and
Flinx start solving that and finally
once you've done all of this sort of
you've done the work of persisting the
data and processing it in let's say a
hundred milliseconds or a second you
need a storage and access system or a
database that is not going to take all
that away away so we talked about
bigquery streaming API here which is
which allows you to get to your data
instantly so now why do you care to make
the shift in your organization right
there's been a lot of success just you
know so many operations teams are in
fact will tell you well we're very happy
to just have our data doesn't matter
that it's fresh doesn't matter that it's
streaming that keeps you give me my data
within an hour when it with an hour of
it being generated I'm great
why do you care there are there are many
reasons to do this and I'll try to sort
of focus on on a couple that often get
overlooked partly because they are a
little bit too close and there seem seem
obvious and partly because in some ways
measuring quality service and sort of
saying ops is a bit is a bit to
measuring quality of service has has
historically been rather difficult so
we've kind of glossed over it so again
the two reasons to care about stream
analytics is that you need fresh data on
your quality of service when things go
wrong with whatever it is that your
company does you should know about it
not in an hour you should know about it
now in ten seconds in a minute right but
not an hour and when you do know about
this you need your operations teams
you're sorry team you know your content
operations your finance operations to
have all the supporting data to resolve
the problem right there and then so you
need fresh data on quality of service
and fresh data on operations so yes
there's some feature deep in your
backlog that's about flying cars and
recommendations and instance sort of an
instant optimization of everything and
a/b testing that is all wonderful but
but stream analytics is about something
much more basic than that it's quality
of service so I'll try to not I'll try
to give you a more concrete example
based on something that I know and sort
of experienced firsthand which is how we
think about quality of service at cloud
pub/sub in GCP and that's generally
representative of how other services are
run at Google so when we launched a few
years back we started with a single SLA
service level agreement that was our
promise to our customers which was that
when your front ends were ready to hand
us off a piece of data an event a log
entry we would be we would accept it
with high likelihood we had four and a
half nines of availability I think when
we started and so that was our SLA and
behind it there was an SLO a service
level objective which is a metric that
was measured in real time right and
someone's pager was connected to it so
if if all of a sudden you couldn't
publish your data your front end said to
accumulate it in there in their memory
and were on their way to crashing
someone's pager was going off and we
would fix it and then we had a bunch of
low volume probers that would exercise
the system sort of different paths
through the system using synthetic
traffic moving on from there we've
designed a brilliant alerting system
which was to use our users as a way to
get us data and when things were things
were going wrong so something would go
wrong with your application let's say
you can create a topic or get you data
you would submit a ticket to our support
system it could get triaged by frontline
support person get escalated to a
specialist get escalated to I to the
engineering team and then finally just
short hours weeks days or weeks later
the issue would be fixed this is of
course sort of being facetious here this
was a horrible system even that was sort
of a step up for for many users because
often times these systems within
individual organizations are run by much
smaller teams but certainly using using
our users as an alerting system or
taking hours to weeks to resolve issues
that wouldn't be
excuse-me beyond
our primary SLA was really no way to
live and so we've changed things a bit
and we said okay let's let's understand
our quality service of service actually
the way our users actually perceive it
and at the end of this exercise rather
sort of at the stage where we are now we
went from sort of one primary user
facing SLA or an SLO backing yet to 234
SLO s that are all connected to
someone's pager and so we said our
promise to the world is really not that
you can publish a message it's not
uptime all right it's our entire API we
publish our you know we publish our API
is a proto buff you can see it and all
of it is a promise so we want to make
sure that the whole thing is working so
we had to look at availability across
all operations in real time we had to
look at not just the success rate but
also the latency of operations I want to
make sure we understood that when things
we're not going going right and Inter in
that respect and we had to sort of
looking deeper at this we had to realize
that it wasn't just about the API our
promise to the world went beyond the API
it wasn't that you could publish a
message and receive a message it was
that the message would be delivered from
a publisher to every single subscriber
turns out that's not an API method all
right it's something synthetic you have
to compute by joining multiple API calls
so we started looking at end-to-end
latency of message delivery and then
finally we had to sort of make all of
this data available so that we could
respond to issues with with any of these
I suppose within minutes and hopefully
get to them before any of our customers
would it would have to submit a ticket
so this is what it looks like today I'm
I've put some some X's there you can ask
me what the actual numbers are just as
an example publish I'm giving you an
example of a publish operations but we
have we have the same thing for others
so we look at the overall method
availability we have to normalize it
somehow
so that
successful traffic from really large
customers doesn't obscure terrible
problems from small volume customers we
have to look at it in each individual
region so here there's us West but we
have to have it in in in every single
region where GCP runs and finally we
have to look at these latency numbers
and then we repeat this for for every
other operation I've talked to I've
talked about into in latency right we
had to measure that also not and that
sort of a straightforward thing to do we
had to look at latency within each
individual region we also make a rather
unique promise to the world which is
that we kid we will delivery message to
wherever your clients are from wherever
they were published so we're a global
service so we had to have operations we
have to have metrics per continent payer
and then finally we had to sort of have
a few s ellos for administrative
operations they're interesting only in
that there are different expectations
around them service so those are
different so having gone through this
exercise we realized that sort of you
know these are metrics from from this
year and I'm very happy with those they
weren't like this when we started the
color was red when we started and that
was the primary sort of the primary
impact of this exercise was to realise
that there's there's there's things are
not well and fixing it so this is a true
humble brag and that this is a brag I'm
very excited that we measure so many
things and we're great at them but this
is also pretty it's a pretty humbling
experience because until we did this it
turned out that there were two hundred
and thirty three dimensions of our
customer experience that we had no idea
about until somebody submitted a ticket
so I bet that's that's happening in your
organization and I think that that in my
mind gets at the core of why stream
analytics and fresh data is important
it's just quality of service I'll answer
I'll try to answer one more question
before I hand this off to the assignment
to talk about sort of how how do you
actually do this these things which is
fine metrics are great as to those are
great and buddy read the SRU book yes
yes I'm seeing I'm saying not again it's
great metrics are great but why do you
need to build new things don't we have
monitoring tools like stackdriver the
four operations metrics and Google
Analytics for content metrics those work
the answer is of course they do and you
should use them for everything you can
but I bet you there's something about
your company that is unique you're in
business because you do something that
is different from what everybody else is
doing alright and so there's going to be
that one metric that is absolutely core
to what your business is that that
you're going to need to compute by
yourself and figure out how to measure
so in the example of pub/sub it seemed
like we kind of had it all under control
right it was just an API and you know
what an API success rate is but then you
get into all these things of like okay
well the API is running in different
regions and there are customer sizes
that that vary by multiple orders of
magnitude how do you how do you
normalize them right how do you make
sure that every customer is happy that's
not a standard sort of thing it's a
value judgment do you have to make for
your business and then you get into
things like end-to-end latency right
again the reason I took you through that
whole story is to just give you a sense
of the depth right you can start getting
at when you start pushing it at the
definition of your of your promise to
the world all right and so with with
end-to-end latency the thing the thing
that was kind of known obvious at first
we started and said all right end-to-end
latency is about a difference between
two timestamps timestamp a message when
it comes in and when somebody says give
me a message you compute the difference
and I made a real value amazing not very
not very interesting no it turns out
that's not the whole story
because what we promise is that if you
give us if you give us enough
opportunities to deliver a message we
will do that but if you're not we can't
be you know we can't have our pages
ringing that's not our promise and so as
it turns out the reasons why we may not
sometimes be able to send you a message
has to do with your client state so
sometimes clients are under provisioned
and maybe you have messages that require
two machines to process but then you
only have one machine or you have a
spike or something right you don't you
don't give us enough opportunities to
deliver messages
latency goes up it's not a systems
problem it's not us breaking your
promise sometimes there are bugs and
clients the you grab you as a client you
get a message you process it and then
you crash before acknowledging it on
four or four Kafka people before
committing the offset right the that we
deliver the message to you we're doing
everything right right but the timestamp
grows sometimes users choose not to not
to consume messages with low latency and
so all of a sudden what this means is
that in order to compute that difference
of timestamps you need to join it with
some kind of stream of understanding of
what your clients are doing for each
individual client and say well is this
client in a healthy state or not and if
it is then you can say okay we trust
this metric all right so all this the
simple timestamp difference it becomes a
complicated thing and this is the thing
that is absolutely at the core of what
we do as a service so I hope that gives
you a sense for why stream analytics is
important to something very basic in
your business again not a thing deep in
the backlog although that will come I'm
sure and I hope it gives you gives you
some ideas for what you might compute if
you had the tools now I will I will stop
with this and I will ask Simon Foreman
up on stage to tell you about his
journey at ITV in doing this
thanks Kira hi everyone i'm simon
foreman head of behavioral data
engineering at itv so let's start there
what's behavioral data engineering
well it's building and running the
systems that capture process and
leverage data from our users as they
visit our web sites use our apps and
watch our shows you might think that
sounds like traditional web analytics
but we actually do a lot more than that
with the data that we have and I'll talk
about that later so to to rewind three
years ago we weren't using GCP at all
and our analytics data was in the hands
of a supplier with all the problems that
that can bring then I wrote our first
prototype streaming dataflow job and
proved that it would work for our
analytics use case but then we had to
take a big leap of faith although I'd
proved the system would work I couldn't
predict how much it would cost to run or
whether it would scale so we took the
risk and I pushed the change to move all
our analytics data over to the new
system on GCP and now I leave the
engineering team as we do more and more
exciting things with behavioral data
ITV's largest commercial broadcaster in
the UK with broadcast TV channels and an
online streaming service used by
millions of people every day last summer
ITV had two massive events the football
World Cup from Russia and the return of
our reality TV hit love Island in the
football England exceeded everyone's
expectations and our audience size
predictions reaching the semi-final
stage that match was watched by 27
million people on our broadcast channel
that's the biggest UK TV audience since
the Olympics in 2012 and even more
impressively almost a million people
streaming the match live online beating
our previous streaming record many times
over love Island also attracted big
audiences every day of its eight-week
run with more of the young audience
choosing to stream rather than watch the
broadcast channel
so both events have lots of viewers but
the load profiles were quite different
football fans tend to start watching
during the pregame show or even a bit
after kickoff giving a long ramp up to
the highest audience I've shown by the
blue line on the graph love Islands a
different story their shows in a
broadcast slot with drama from the very
first minute so fans arrive on mass just
as it starts the steep green line shows
just how quickly the audience goes from
zero to hundreds of thousands in just a
couple of minutes these audiences
generate huge amounts of data for my
team systems and give us the challenge
of collecting all in real time and
scaling our processing systems to handle
it without slowing down I'm going to
talk about how we build and run the
systems that handle that data on GCP
starting with our goals for the project
now although we run a video-on-demand
service our busiest events are actually
live streaming so we had to be ready for
those surges that means the collection
system has to scale quickly but the rest
of it needs to keep up or we'll have
angry consumers waiting for the data
that they need in the near future
we'll have to handle a lot more data as
people continue to shift their attention
to online streaming and we incorporate
other data sources we want to avoid
growing the team at the same rate so we
lean heavily on managed services with
low operational support requirements
bigquery and cloud functions are really
good examples of this we want people to
trust our data trust that it's complete
and that it's accurate and we want the
front-end engineering teams to have an
easy job of implementing data reporting
for us and finally we want to our
downstream consumers like data
scientists to be able to use the data we
share with them as a foundation for
their work without doing any tedious
cleanup beforehand GCP and especially
pub/sub and bigquery make it very easy
to deploy new applications that use data
without any risk to existing ones now
I'm going to show you some examples of
what our systems actually
like starting with the one that receives
data from our users all of our apps and
sites have embedded code that sends
small pieces of data back to simple
receiver services using HTTP these
services are either cloud functions or
run on compute engine the one that
handles video playback events has to be
able to cope with sudden surges from
people watching live events so we use
sensitively configured auto scaling to
handle those highs without spending a
fortune on excess capacity this service
does minimal processing of the events it
receives the strategy is to get them
onto a pub sub topic as quickly as
possible having everything go through
pub/sub means we can plug in different
consumers very easily in one case we
have 13 consumers for one topic on the
right of this diagram there's a dataflow
job writing to bigquery this stores
everything in its raw format and it's a
pattern that we repeat on most topics
whether they're dealing with raw data
like this case or aggregated often this
archives needed for audit purposes so we
have to store it but it's also been very
helpful for debugging or to replay
historical data through a new job we
considered a file based storage for this
instead of bigquery but there wasn't
much difference in the cost and having
the data online in a way that was easily
queried was a really nice benefit and
now moving on to a more complex system
this diagram shows the flow of video
playback and site interaction data
through two data flow jobs that first
summarize then session eyes it
summarizing means turning possibly
hundreds of events from one video stream
into a single summary of the important
bits who the user was what sure they
watched how long they watched it for and
so on this jobs data source is the same
topic the ingest service on the previous
slide was pushing to session izing is
pulling together all of the video
summaries and site interaction
for each user session and delivering
them downstream as bundle this job reads
summaries from the summarizes output
topic and raw site interaction data from
another one and publishes to its own
output topic hanging off the session
eise's topic is a cloud function that
applies some formatting before pushing
to another topic that we use as the
handoff to a third party this gives them
lots of flexibility about how they pull
that data be it streaming or batch or
even push in this diagram you can also
see to bigquery logging jobs that store
all the video summaries and the session
i's data in tables and now on to a
dataflow job that gives us real-time
quality of service data this data shows
us how our video streaming service is
performing and lets ITV's operations
team quickly jump on any problem the job
reads for all video playback events and
aggregates them then publishes to a
topic typically with just 30 seconds of
delay between a user having a problem
like rebuffering and that being
reflected in the output data from the
topic we write to bakery for long-term
storage and analysis and we push to
Splunk for live dashboards and alerting
and in the last example of architecture
i'll show you how the cross device
resume feature works this is a product
feature where you can pick up where
you're playing on a different device say
going from an iPhone to a smart TV we
push a subset of the same video event
data using a node.js app into Redis and
expose this to the front-end apps
through a cloud function latency is
absolutely critical here so we're
willing to trade some reliability to
reduce it we were able to save a heap of
time and build this feature without
adding any position logging code to the
front-end apps by reusing the data we
already had and building a service to
expose it in a new way so that was a
look at some of the things that we've
built
now on to how we run them our internal
customers care about data accuracy we
replaced an old analytic system and we
have to be at least as good as it was by
that measure they want data without any
delay so that they can use it to power
real time product features and drive
operational reporting and they want us
to quickly build new applications and
incorporate more data sources into
existing ones and to support this we
have metrics SL eyes that we watch at
the ingest stage we don't want any
errors we want to collect all the data
and get it safely onto a pub sub topic
and we want that data to be high quality
it needs to match the spec for required
fields and suitable values once we have
the data and it's well-formed we need to
process it quickly and a good way to
check that's happening is looking at the
size of the backlogs and the pub sub
subscriptions we use and lastly
saturation it's important to make sure
we're not getting close to any capacity
limits to avoid delaying or even worse
losing any data now I'll show you some
of the dashboards to demonstrate this
the first one shows how we monitor the
video data summarize a job you can think
of this job in classical input process
output terms it pulls messages from a
pub sub subscription the input apply
some business logic that's the process
then outputs video summaries the graphs
here show how each of those stages is
behaving the two on the far left show
the rate that data is being published to
the input topic and how much of that
hasn't yet been consumed by the data
flow job a backlog here would indicate
the job not keeping up with a source
data rate and consequently delaying its
output but the spikes in the graph here
are short-lived just a couple of minutes
and of course by the job auto scaling up
and down so they're not something to
worry about in the higher middle graph
there's a view of the data flow jobs lag
which is a measure of the oldest data
still being processed if this is
elevated output data will again be
delayed below that is what the auto
scaling system is doing
we want this to roughly move in line
with the input data volume if it isn't
that could be an indication of a problem
for example hitting the maximum but
still needing more resources to keep up
top right is a custom metric we added
code to the data flow job to increment a
counter whenever conditions hit in this
case it's counting malformed source data
data that we can't process because it
doesn't have all the fields we need we
want this to stay a low fraction of the
input rate if it deviates from that
trend we could have a problem with our
data sources and lastly the lower-right
graph shows how many summaries are being
produced the final output stage a drop
here means the job isn't producing the
data it should be taken together these
graphs show the jobs overall health and
if there's a problem what the likely
cause is this dashboard looks at one of
our engineers systems the pot that
handles the firehose of data coming in
from our apps and sites I'm a big fan of
the SR ebooks for gold and signals
traffic latency errors and saturation
and they're monitored here at the
top-left the view of the request rate
split by response code any problems with
the service would show up here as 500s
there usually aren't any both so that
that hugs the x-axis below that is the
services latency how quickly it's
publishing the piece of data to pub/sub
and returning and ok back to the app the
apps aren't actually latency sensitive
and we're not affecting the user
experience at all by being slow here but
increased latency does drastically
reduce the services capacity so could
turn into a full outage if it continues
or becomes more widespread the orange
green and purple graph shows the
services own view of how quickly pub/sub
is accepting data again taking from the
SRA book the time each published
operation takes is bucketed and counted
this gives a high-resolution view
without storing and graphing millions of
data points every minute
everything in the orange region and
above it is quicker than 100
milliseconds with just a small number of
requests taking longer than that you
might see them in the lower right area
of the graph
and lastly saturation the two graphs in
the top right are from the auto scaling
groups monitoring
obviously hitting the upper configured
limit is bad but we also want to see the
instance count CPU and request request
rate roughly moving in sync with each
other and this last dashboard it's just
how we monitor the data feed out to a
partner a pub/sub subscription is the
boundary between our two organizations
we publish data to it and our partner
pulls it so the key metrics are the
publish rate and the pull rate on the
top row if these stay balanced we won't
get a backlog and data won't be delayed
if a backlog has grown the lower two
graphs show how much data in how many
messages is waiting to be consumed the
spike in the center of the graphs was
less for a problem than it then its
shape suggests and the backlog was only
a few seconds worth of data and it
cleared quite quickly so that was how we
take care of running systems but how do
we deploy code when streaming jobs
around 24/7 things are a bit different
with streaming and updating cloud
functions and simple compute engine apps
is easy there's no state so they're
naturally easy to change online dataflow
jobs that do hold state are much harder
stopping and starting isn't an option as
that would lose some output data or
introduced in accuracy the best solution
is to live update the running job using
data flows built-in feature this is
quick and easy in fact we have data flow
jobs that are updated automatically by a
continuous deployment system but it's
sometimes not possible to use this
feature if there's a significant
difference in the job structure or the
codes not compatible so we needed a
smarter way to release fixes and
improvements without stopping the job
our solution for the video summarizer
process is to start the updated job
while the old one is still running the
new one gets its own input subscription
so it'll get a copy of the same data as
the old one but having two running
causes a problem the new job will also
be a missing data at best
causing duplication or if it doesn't
have the full state producing data
that's just incorrect we need it away
for the new job to wait until it had all
the state it needed before it started
outputting anything and we needed the
old job to stop producing data at
exactly the same time so that there was
no duplication synchronizing the two
jobs looked very complex and couldn't
even guarantee exactly one's output so
we looked for a way for them to
coordinate without any direct
communication the thing we came up with
was to use a characteristic of the
output data here at the start time with
a video stream as the deciding factor we
pick a point in time and say any data
from before then comes from the old job
and anything after that point comes from
the new job to implement this we added a
feature to the job where it could
conditionally drop data instead of
publishing it to the output topic it
still reads all the source data applies
the same logic but just doesn't publish
the result so to go through the whole
deployment process to start with the old
version is running that's the green line
and it's emitting data to the output
topic the green boxes then we deploy the
new version the blue line and specify a
cut over time some hours in the future
and we reconfigure the old job with the
same cut over time we'll be able to see
metrics from the new job showing that
it's working as expected but if it isn't
we can just stop it and look into why
when data is produced for after the cut
over time it'll come from the new job
that's the blue boxes on the diagram
after a while the old job
using anything so we can stop it and
clear up its subscription so that's a
quick tour of our current work what
about the future
so we already support personalization
features across our apps and we're going
to build even more of them often using
the same data we already have we're
working on ad tech to help our
commercial teams deliver more value to
our advertisers our platform provides a
way for data scientists to quickly and
easily put their research into
production and work on challenges like
improving marketing effectiveness and
better understand their audiences and
how they use our products to increase
engagement and thanks to the capacity we
have we can begin to collect data from
from our enormous broadcast audiences
gaining extra insight into our viewers
so to reflect on what we've achieved we
provide high quality data quality is
embedded throughout the pipeline from
how we build our front end apps through
validating the data we receive to
checking that what we've what we're
producing is correct our data is trusted
by the people who use it they know it's
accurate and they happily rely on it
it's available immediately are streaming
jobs deliver useful process data without
any delay and we support real-time
personalization features last summer
we had more online viewers and
successfully collected many times more
data than ever before while maintaining
our latency and reliability SLO s and we
did that without any reengineering this
gives us confidence to handle the next
tenfold increase as more people move
they're viewing online and we begin to
collect data from broadcast services
what started as an experiment with one
data flow job has turned into a mature
data platform that supports analytics
operational operations and front end
product features and sets us up for a
future of more and more data based
applications thank you back to you here
[Applause]
thank Simon alright we're almost there
so I hope this gave you a sort of a
flavour of what that shift the streaming
looks like yes it's a shift you have to
do a little bit of work in both how you
think and how you organize your systems
in engineering but perhaps this makes it
more familiar we also hope that the this
this idea of of stream analytics being
core to your your quality of service
data is an interesting is an interesting
reason to take back to your job and and
sort of feel empowered to not just
implement new features and move data
from databases to database to databases
which is absolutely critical but also do
something that is I'm sort of
fundamental to what your company to what
your company does so clearly there's a
lot more than that that you can do with
with real-time data but that's just sort
of one reason before we part I wanted to
or rather before we shift to QA I wanted
to touch on a couple things so a few
features that have to do with running
pipelines running stream analytics
pipelines in real life that have come
out in recent time in sort of recent
months that I wanted to highlight as
well as a few more sessions that we'll
go deeper into some of the some aspects
of this topic that we haven't gotten a
chance to touch on
so first the the newer features and
cloud pub/sub what's very important for
operating these systems is the ability
to to replay data so to recover from
problems that's not possible you can
also you are now also able to discard
messages in our events in bulk also look
out for upcoming controls on where data
is stored in this global service as well
as new new ways of sort of optimising
costs where we've split off egress data
and local usage data on data flow stream
engine a streaming engine which which is
hit G a recently is a very interesting
thing and that it offloads a lot of the
state away from individual processing
nodes which makes the modus
and so stable and also much more
flexible in terms of optimization so
streaming out of scaling now works much
more granularly and of course in real
life not everybody loves Java which is
data flows primary or first language so
Python streaming is is now in beta for
for data flow and if you stick around
the conference there may be a couple
more languages that we would be
announcing so speaking of that here's
some sessions you might hit I know they
say that these are these are booked but
as you can see there's always a seat you
could find and also there'll be videos
and slides slides I'm pretty sure are
posted after the conference so the the
particular I would like to highlight the
third Thursday sections because the
titles are a bit on nondescript the 1140
session d a three-on-one is going to
dive into data flow and sort of ortho
what's what's happening there it's gonna
be a reasonably deep session the end
2:35 on Thursday GCP for Apache Kafka
users is going to cover this topic from
the perspective of I'm not using
necessarily our native tools but looking
at the at Kafka is sort of a common
departure point for this with that
that's all our content I I think you get
a you get a chance to rate us the way
you do this is you open the app and you
find the fifth star and your press on it
if you don't feel that you can do that
and maintain you maintain your integrity
come yell at us in person we love
hearing feedback
[Music]